[Music]
foreign
agency the gru has suffered what we
could call some significant setbacks in
recent weeks after of course the botched
attempt to kill the former Russian agent
at Sergio scripple in Salisbury they
remain however a big and powerful
organization who shouldn't be
underestimated and that is according to
the former head or the secret
intelligence Services better known as
MI6 so let's have a listen in to what he
told me
Clifton a familiar backdrop for spies
and Scandal famously playing host to the
perfumer affair today the house is home
to among other things a literary
Festival which is where I sat down with
the former head of MI6 Sir Richard
dearlov he rarely gives interviews and
hasn't spoken publicly since the attack
in Salisbury I started by asking him
about brexit I'm personally happy to see
us
ceasing to be a member of the EU but I
think as I said or have said before I
don't think you should see that as us
leaving Europe it's leaving a European
treaty and we would obviously still have
a very very close relationship with
Continental Europe why are you
personally happy do you see
opportunities to perhaps Forge New
alliances essentially you know I see it
as an issue of sovereignty
so I think that's a very important point
um
as I said in the past you know we've
never been
part of
Continental Europe's political Ambitions
to create you know a more Federated
Union we've always opposed that
and I mean I think that the EU in its
current form I'm not suggesting it's
going to disappear but it radically
needs change
and if it's going to have an inner core
which is you know politically motivated
we're never ever going to be an
enthusiastic part of that so a good time
to diverge then if it's becoming a a
closer politically I think it's a
natural point of Divergence for us and
I'm not underestimating the difficulties
of leaving but I'm absolutely confident
that we can survive
and thrive
outside the Continental allowance but
still be a major player in European
geopolitics is
to leaving the alliance at this point
when you have Donald Trump in the White
House the Great disrupter
somebody who is a nationalist he says
extraordinary things
um
you know he clearly behaves
unpredictably he clearly
I was going to say needs babysitting
without sounds rather insulting way of
talking about the president of the
United States whoever it is but on the
other hand I think there's still you
know a real solidity in the
anglo-american alliance
I'm interested in your um thoughts about
somebody another perhaps unpredictable
political figure uh Jeremy corbyn a man
that you've previously described as a
danger to this nation what did you mean
by that well I think someone coming from
my background
is troubled
by
Jeremy corbyn's past associations
um
some of which I find
surprising and worrying
he may have abandoned them now
but I don't think you can entirely as it
would dump your past what past
associations do you mean well he has
managed to be an enthusiastic
uh
well he he's enthusiastically a stated
Associated himself with groups and
interests which I would not say with the
friends of the British Nation there is a
real possibility that he could be the
next prime minister I mean could you see
a scenario when the security services
are effectively withholding information
from him uh no and if he becomes prime
minister he becomes prime minister that
will be the Democratic decision of the
British people and in that position
um certainly not I mean you have to
treat him as prime minister so I
wouldn't uh as it uh I'm expressing
concerns about him and his political
past which I think are pretty
extensively shared by a lot of people
now some people close to Jeremy corbyn
and have said that the the Deep state if
by which they mean the security services
is is hostile to a labor government and
might even use kind of dirty tricks
against it I mean Andrew Murray for
example suggesting in an article in the
new Statesman that the fact that he was
denied a security pass
um May because be because of what he
called the maneuverings of a deep State
I mean do you think they're right that's
rubbish
I mean I think you do every
government has been loyally served by
the British security and intelligence
community and I imagine that every
future government would be loyally
served and so I I absolutely do not
agree with that and I particularly like
this concept of a deep State and somehow
that some Sinister power I mean it's
just
is
you know sort of conspiratorial thinking
which I think is inappropriate in a
political context and a modern democracy
do you think though that the Security
Services has a responsibility to do its
part to combat that kind of thinking
though I mean by being more transparent
by being more open by being more
accountable there is a secrecy
surrounding it
I think that you know there's much
greater transparency
than the used to be I mean that's
developed significantly even here we
have
parliamentary oversight committee for
the intelligence of the security
Community as part of the intelligence
and Security Act
um
and
they need to keep their secrets but on
the other hand
to suggest that the British Community is
not under full political control is
just not the case I'm Keen to talk to
you as well about Russia in the wake of
what's happened in Salisbury and how big
a setback is it for you know an
Espionage unit like the gru to be
effectively blown open in what happened
in Salisbury well it does look like a
rather
incompetent
operation
and
an operation which you know was probably
not sufficiently well prepared if they
had a specific objective
um yes I mean it's a damage is their
reputation but
you know the giu is a big powerful
well-funded organization and you know we
shouldn't underestimate the problems
that they can still cause even
when they've had a significant setback
and of course what it does also do is
underline the threat to the UK from
Russia
um
do you think that more needs to be done
to combat that threat from Russia
because it does feel as if
no little has changed really we're no
longer in the Cold War
and I don't see the threat that Russia
presents now is equivalent to the
situation that we had during the Cold
War
um however
a Russian Espionage Soviet Espionage has
never stopped
it's deeply embedded in Russia's DNA
to use
the capabilities that it has to disrupt
other nations to pursue you know their
own national interests
to as it were reinforced Putin in power
and
you know this is uh actually the the the
attack in the UK and I think fits a
historical pattern
Russia historically as always used
assassination as a weapon it's part of
the Russian political DNA it's rather
terrible thing to say but
it's a violent country and they tend to
kill each other one way I guess if
tackling the Russian threat I mean this
was an attack carried on UK sport wasn't
it
um would be to look at Russian money in
London I mean the current the House of
Commons Foreign Affairs Select Committee
for example putting out report in May
2018 uh saying very explicitly you know
the assets stored and laundered in
London both directly and indirectly
support President Putin's campaign to
subvert the International rules-based
System undermine our allies and erode
the mutually reinforcing International
networks that support UK foreign policy
I mean is that something that should be
looked at well my understanding it is
being looked at and um you know there's
a change in legislation now in terms of
the powers the government has
to confiscate you know unexplained
assets
yeah inevitably one should look more
closely at these issues but
you know one has to draw a distinction
between
rations or Russian Nationals in the
Russian State okay some of them maybe
closely you know associated with Putin
and Putin's regime I mean others may not
be so it's not a sort of black and white
issue in my opinion how worried are you
as well about
um Russian attempts to influence
democracy in the west the U.S election
in the brexit thing well they have a
formidable clandestine capability which
has been applied to social media
Russia has always
disrupted politically those Nations
which it has seen
as
both hostile and now you know you could
put a slightly lower level and friendly
to it
um okay I think we've been quite shocked
to discover the recent extent of
meddling But there again you know this
has a historic pattern I mean it's
usually been exercised by the Russians
in relation
to the countries in its immediate
periphery which in essence the time of
Ivan the Terrible it set out to weaken
the polities
around Russia to make sure that you know
there was no immediate threat
and in a way you know it's an extension
and continuation in very modern terms
of that type of approach we talked a lot
about Russia and just finally I'm
interested in your thoughts on what are
the big security threats facing Britain
now at this time that we're in obviously
terrorism remains a problem
um migration I think remains a major
problem
the whole issue of
you know our dependence on Cyber
capability and of the difficulty we're
having
in a controlling cyber from a security
point of view so you know there's
enumeration of problems which some of
which are very new and some of which
fit into a very well established
geopolitical pattern but quite an
uncertain moment globally well I think
we're in a rather extraordinary moment
historically which is both exciting
and will contain opportunities
but also you know might look like a
cliff Edge
if we make poor decisions or we don't
have the right sort of political
leadership